Greetings fellow earthlings today we're going to talk about the technology
within Star Trek that has become true today.
Star Trek is known for predicting tons of technological achievements, such as:
cell phones, bluetooth, flat screen tvs,
Skype, iPads, and talking computers.
"Hello computer."  All of these gadgets exist in the Star Trek universe
far before they became a reality and now we're gonna update you on the new
developments in technology.
The first item on our list is something you probably already heard of
"Virtual Display" AKA Google Glass. In Star Trek members the super evil group
"the Dominion" didn't bother using flat screen monitors to surf the web but
trippy looking headsets with one eye piece
that projected computer imagery through their optic nerve and into their brain.
They could watch streaming video of the outside of the ship, receive messages.,
and video chat with other evil Dominion leaders just like Google Glass.
Next, let's revisit a classic that finally being made today.
"The Medical Tricorder." That would prove to have virtually no limitations in terms of scanning
It is most famous for its ability to diagnose pretty much anything.
"Sever theta radiation poisoning."
Today's equivalent of tricorders are capable of diagnosing most ailments.
in the human body without needing to see a doctor.
Just by placing on your left temple, the Scanadu Scout
can provide results for pulse transit time, heart rate
temperature, blood oxygenation and more.
Diagnosing anything from abdominal cramps to shingles,
it's quite an upgrade from your thermometer.
Next up on our list, an overlooked essential for all interstellar space travel.
"transparent aluminum?"
what do you think space windows were made of?
When the Enterprise crew traveled back to 1986
Scotty handed over the formula for creating the super-strong, yet incredibly thin glass
that proved to hold up against nearly everything the universe threw at it.
"That's the ticket laddie."
Due to Scotty's interference with the timeline,
the transparent aluminum armor is now marketed as "Alon"
by the Surmet corporation.
The armor can resist a fifty-caliber armor-piercing bullet and anti-aircraft weapons
all while being half the weight and thickness of typical bullet-proof glass.
Okay, let's move on to something that will truly change your life.
"Computer, one slice of New York cheesecake"
"The Food Replicator"
It's the biggest menu, the fastest delivery,
and will probably make you gain fifty pounds if you owned one.
The food replicators featured in Star Trek reproduced any food stuff programed into it's database
with a single voice command.  "the replicator to make anything you desire"
"How do I know what I desire?"
The real version looks like this!
Okay, it's not quite as fast but it's
freshly made food at the touch of a button!
Just recently, NASA has commissioned a design of a 3D food printer
capable of making pizza... in space.
to satisfy the indulgences of astronauts... which is the best use of tax dollars.
Happy with our list?  "NOOO!"
Well, we can't please-- "NOOO!"
Calm down... thanks for watching! Subscribe for more wonderful things.